vous allez être immergé dans le circuit
jusqu'au bout une immersion dans une
formule électrique ds automobile sur le
circuit du grand prix de monaco
l'expérience proposée au ministre
délégué en charge des transports jean
baptiste djebbari un essai notamment
pour comprendre le fonctionnement de la
technologie électrique dans le sport
automobile est vraiment tout un travail
autour du pilotage lieu et un gros
travail que j'ignorais en tout cas dont
je n'avais pas complètement compris
l'ampleur sur la gestion d'énergie
l'idée étant d'utiliser l'énergie à bord
pour
partiellement la régénérer pendant la
course et donc finir avec
le minimum d'électricité mais finir
quand même
ce simulateur de formule électrique est
située sur le site sté lantiss
motorsport à versailles-satory un outil
destiné aux pilotes pour l'entraînement
et la préparation des courses chaque
pilote fasse de l'ordre de 5 jours ici
sur le site a préparé la course avant
chaque événement donc une semaine avant
avant la course ils viennent ici pour
s'entraîner préparer les courses réviser
les stratégies apprendre les circuits
travail avec leurs ingénieurs pour
arriver aussi près que possible sur le
sur l'événement de la course ce site du
groupe issu de la fusion entre psa et
fiat chrysler est spécialisée dans le
sport automobile 230 personnes
travaillent ici de la formule eds
automobile au programme d'endurance de
peugeot sport avec une stratégie
orientée de plus en plus vers
l'électrique l'objectif c'est vraiment
d'appuyer d'appuyer la formule
électrique qui est qui a pour objectif
de développer la l'électrification de
l'automobile en général la spécificité
des courses électrique c'est plutôt des
courses urbaines sous les temps assez
court 45 minutes donc avec des vitesses
moyennes un peu un peu inférieur à ce
qu'on connaît en formule 1 donc on n'est
pas tout à fait seulement registre de
course mais
mais en tout cas ça porte sur le plan du
développement et des applications sur
les véhicules de série ça porte ses
fruits ds automobile deviendra une
marque 100 % électrique à partir de 2024